ich habe auf diesem kanal schon
unendlich gute und unendliche hotels
getestet darunter das brenner's in
baden-baden was als teuerstes hotel
deutschlands gilt das four seasons in
hamburg was als bestes hotel
deutschlands gilt ich habe mich
allerdings noch nie mit der frage
beschäftigt wo man einkehren kann wenn
man geld wie normalsterbliche ausgeben
will so um die 100 euro und vor allem wo
der unterschied zwischen dem 100 euro
hotel in deutschland um den new york
genau das wenn wir in diesem video
herausfinden ich habe die besten hotels
dem buch die man für 100 euro bekommen
kann wo die unterschiede sind und
welches der hotels gewinnt erfahrt ihr
in diesem video und bevor hier irgendwas
seht vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren und dem video einen leichter
zu lassen um mich und das gesamte
projekt viel spaß mit den hotels
wir starten mit dem hotel in deutschland
und ich habe schon lange darauf gewartet
euch dieses hotel beziehungsweise diese
kette zu zeigen denn ist mein absolutes
ko hotel egal in welcher stadt ich bin
wenn es einfache ausgibt dann schlafe
ich dort warum das so ist und wie die
zimmer aussehen das zeige ich euch jetzt
wir machen auch herzlich willkommen im
juli fällt war
[Musik]
für mich wie ein angestellter das ist
das zimmer herzlich willkommen im
training aus wie gesagt mein gott uhr
hotel ich zeige euch noch einmal im
detail wie das raum dass raum wieder
raum aufgebaut ist also das hier ist er
ein ganz große spiegel und vergleichend
kleine arbeitsbereich ein telefon mit
wählscheibe erstmal grundsätzlich ich
will es ziemlich gut die offen was alles
gestattet ist außerdem cool wir haben so
eine betondecke das gibt dem ganzen so
lockt stil nichts besonderes das werden
wir gleich noch testen nur die fernseher
warnt hier nochmal mehr möglichkeiten
sagen aufzuhängen und hiermit genügte
nur dann vorstellen ein und ausstellen
der geht weiter ins bad finde ich auch
meist nicht nur charakterlos einfach
markiert schon getraut sich farbe zu
nutzen der eingeleiteten spiel wennigloh
und eine offene machen sollte also schon
die man hier in diesen zu verdächtigen
den mann gut kennt wenn man nicht gerade
allein ist hier ist noch das bad war das
schauen und dergleichen die noch einmal
im detail an der ausblick naja was soll
ich sagen es ist zumindest ein reales
bild von köln die lage ist super gut man
ist mittendrin man es direkt an den
ringen aber nicht auf den ringen was
ziemlich wichtig ist weil sonst wird an
den wochenenden ziemlich laut man es
unweit des belgischen viertels also drei
gehminuten das ist der ort an dem man
sich eigentlich aufhalten will wenn man
in köln ist allgemeines köln aber
relativ klein also man kann hier fast
mit der lage nichts falsch machen die
lage ist aber gut ja sehr gut finde ist
habe mich aber trotzdem gefreut und mir
ist gerade aufgefallen wir haben
richtigen parkettboden und hieraus zu
einem weiteren richtigen punkt die mit
war alles da drin ist komplett for free
und wir nehmen uns direkt ticona sehr
cool ziemlich basic aber alles was man
braucht und chips kinder regel wasser
bier und cola und minibar zurück neben
dem fernseher steht eine karte es gibt
nämlich auch in restaurants sind alle 25
aus ist dass sich neben and und
glücklicherweise drehen wir heute in
köln das bedeutet ich kann das
restaurant mit dem einzig wahren
restauranttester max gleich mal unter
die lupe nehmen
[Musik]
also auf den ersten blick und mit dem
bloßen auge sieht dass hier schon sehr
gut aus wir kommen aber natürlich wie
immer so königs ist glücklicherweise hat
das paar hat keine fenster was ist uns
deutlich einfach macht das ganze hier zu
testen also die armaturen den ok heraus
in den ecken sieht man schon dass ein
bisschen staub und so da ist nichts
dramatisches aber auch viel angepackt
wird und so sieht auch gut aus dem boden
das war nichts zu erkennen aussagt ist
meine schuhe etwas leuchten
der toilette immer problemzone gar
nichts und jetzt die königsdisziplin
nichts nicht mal unter der klobrille und
genau dieses gefühl hatte ich schon
immer wenn ich hier geschlafen habe
[Musik]
das bett ist schon hart also ist jetzt
keinen bock springt oder so ist es nicht
zu vergleichen mit dem bett im brenners
oder im four seasons das ist ein
deutlich einfacheres bett aber es ist
okay es ist okay aber wartet mal wie
kriege ich überhaupt hin überall auf der
welt in all den hotelzimmern in denen
ich schlafe meine lieblingsserie
umzuschauen deswegen wird dieses video
freundlicherweise von nord vpn
unterstützt mit nord vpn habt ihr die
möglichkeit euren standort zu einem der
5212 über 60 ländern mit einem klick zu
wechseln es hilft euch nicht nur eure
lieblings serien von überall auf der
welt schauen zu können sondern auch
streaming anbieter zu einem günstigeren
preis zu finden ist wird einfach eure
locations und bezahlt den preis von dort
um das ist sehr nice und keine angst
danken notebooks müsst ihr euch keine
gedanken darüber machen dass euer
internet langsamer wird ist bleibt quasi
so schnell wie es ist und ihr könnt das
pro form von videos vermeiden und auch
abseits der eben genannten punkte ist es
super smart neue vpn zu nutzen einfach
um sich selber im internet zu schützen
und sich weniger angreifbar für word zu
machen blickt jetzt auf den ersten link
in der video beschreibung
www.nordphoto.de vpn für einen
exklusiven deal gebt ihr komplettes
creed testen könnt weil es eine 30 tage
geld zurück garantie vom neubau werden
gibt ich bedanke mich vielmals bei nord
vpn dass die mich und die gesamte
projekte unterstützen dieses video
möglich gemacht haben klickt auf den
ersten link in der video beschreibung
und jetzt viel spaß weiterhin mit dem
video
hier seht einfach alles wirklich gut und
durchdacht aus der aufzug sieht cool aus
wurde von allen installierten in köln
komplett auseinandergenommen deswegen
kann man gehe jetzt nichts mehr machen
als sie trotz alledem immer noch cool
aus machte eindruck vom aufzug hier
würde ich ein instagram foto machen aber
sowas von sofort
also ich war ja schon das ein oder
andere mal im kölner restaurants
unterwegs und muss wirklich sagen so von
location vom ambiente her ist das schon
in den top top top restaurants in köln
allgemein ist für die fed aus einfach
gut gemacht das merkt man auch im
restaurant essen
habe ich was ihn erinnere ich sage
nichts dazu aber ich bin gespannt wie es
heute sein wird
[Musik]
und es ist gerade schon etwas
aufgefallen also tatsächlich könnte es
sein dass hier auf der karte nicht jeder
fündig liegt das restaurant hat einen
ganz klaren orientalischen touch und die
gerichte sind an vielen ecken schon
wirklich speziell für alle leute die am
liebsten pommes oder nun könnte er
tatsächlich schon schwer werden
okay wir hatten schon abend aber wie gut
war das essen wirklich dafür habe ich
dem profi max an die seite geholt und er
wird das neni kurz für uns begonnen
location mit einer der besten in köln
diese lage in der höhe mit dem ausblick
gibt es so ganz selten in köln
ausstattung superschön
karte da muss man schon bock auf etwas
ausgefallenes haben um da auf seine
kosten zu kommen wenn man aber bock auf
so was hat dann ist es wirklich gut es
ist aber jetzt nicht unter meinen top
ten in köln so es ist grundsolide und
nicht um auf den preis noch einzugehen
er ist angemessen für das rennen oder
vollkommen im rahmen aber sozusagen
sieben von zehn ich würde so 88 und halb
sogar geben für mich sind acht von zehn
haben zu sagen wir 815 tiptop was soll
ich sagen das hotel ist unglaublich gut
durchdacht und das merkt man bei
einfachen dingen wie steckdosen direkt
am bett lichtschalter auf beiden seiten
des bettes die man eigentlich erwarten
kann die trotzdem in manchen hotels
ferien geht weiter ein bisschen zu
nachruhm einer bluetooth box die man
nicht nur im hotel nutzen kann sondern
die man überall mit hinnehmen kann
solange man gast des hotels ist dazu
sind die zimmer hell groß offen sauber
es gibt eine kostenlose mini bar was
einem einfach als gast ein unglaublich
gutes gefühl gibt ich will mich hier
einfach wirklich wohl und genau deswegen
und nicht ohne grund ist dass sie mein
gott hotel in paris in wien in berlin in
ganz vielen anderen stellen jetzt gilt
es aber noch zu testen kann es in
irgendeiner weise mit dem hotel in new
york
ich habe mich nämlich von jemandem
beraten lassen wäre eine menge ahnung
hat welches vermutlich das beste hotel
gerade in new york ist preis
leistungsmäßig vom standort von den
zimmern soll es wohl dass sein weil das
zimmer was ich gemacht habe ist völlig
okay
1/22 stock schon ordentlich hoch ich
kann es gar nicht so richtig einschätzen
wie hoch werden jetzt gleich sehen bei
möglicherweise hat das ja was mit dem zu
müssen ok willkommen im scheinbar besten
hotel new yorks
ich weiß ganz typisches greifen
[Musik]
wir haben ein zimmer im 22 stock mit
einer glasfront quasi einmal komplett
außen rum um unser bett für einen preis
der wirklich unschlagbar ist aber wir
starten mal ganz vorne das hier ist
unser eingangsbereich unsere tür durch
die wir gerade gekommen sind und direkt
neben der tür befindet sich ein kleines
bad dusche auf den ersten blick sieht
super aus für das ist jetzt nicht
negativ serie ist aber alles was nur
rausschauen keine ahnung diesen ganzen
standard crm und eben einen normal
geräumiges bad alles was man braucht
sieht cool modern und ziemlich frisch
aus ist jetzt nicht absolut top aber da
kann man wirklich gar nichts aussetzen
das ist ein gutes blatt einen spiegel
neben dem eingangsbereich damit man sich
noch mal geschenkt haben bevor man raus
in die see geht in der sed absolut
niemanden interessieren wie man aussieht
wenn man komplett untergeht weil diese
stadt viel zu riesig ist und direkt
daneben befindet sich unser waschbecken
das finde ich ein bisschen komisch dass
es nicht im bad mit drin aber es ist
eben nur begrenzt platz deswegen würde
ich sagen ist das auch okay finde ich
nicht mega cool aber stört mich jetzt
auch nicht ein zweiter spiegel zweimal
wasser das dazu gehört ein bisschen
ablagefläche und direkt nebendran eine
arbeitsfläche an der man ein bisschen
arbeiten kann aber jetzt auch nicht muss
denn jeder der schon mal an einer
tischplatte gearbeitet hat die so dick
ist weiß dass es unangenehm ist ein mann
einfach keine komfortable sitzposition
finden wird und direkt gegenüber
befindet sich unser schrank bereich
einmal so ein offener teil und dann hier
oben nochmal ordentlich stockum es ist
jetzt kein safe oder so dabei das ist
für mich jetzt kein muss weiß ich nicht
ob das jetzt so cool ist das kein safe
drin ist aber es gibt eine sache die das
natürlich alles wieder wett macht und
das ist dieser bereich ich habe hinter
mir jetzt noch ein bisschen licht an
deswegen sieht das noch weniger
eindrucksvoll aus als aussehen kann das
machen wir auch noch aus und dann sieht
es so aus und in echt sieht es noch mal
deutlich krasse aus als auf kamera wir
haben hier oben über dem bett ein
fernseher die werde ich aber vermutlich
nicht benutzen denn ich habe diese stadt
kulisse direkt vor meinen augen hier ist
ein doppelbett queen size
ist ebenso gebucht ich bin alleine
unterwegs man hätte das auch als king
size buchen können aber eine sache die
dieses zimmer eben ausmacht ist der
preis und deswegen queen size alleine
reisen ist dieser preis glaube ich
unschlagbar also ich meine guckt euch
das mal an wenn man hier jetzt einfach
mal liegt
nach einem tag in der stadt
es ist schon ein absoluter traum und das
brett fühlt sich sehr gut an es gibt
niemanden im direkten blickfeld der bei
einem reinschauen kann das einzige
haustier direkt nebendran es ist noch
ungewohnt also da werden glaube ich
gerade frische wohnungen gebaut dass da
vorne sieht aus wie ein geschäftshaus
und die anderen häuser sind gar nicht so
hoch wie man selber also man hat nur
gute aussicht aber fast niemand
kokereien also hier direkt gegenüber es
eben auch kein haus wo jemand
reinschauen kann es ist wirklich schon
sehr meist da ich aber seit nunmehr 28
schutzbach drin werde ich mich als
erstes mal hinlegen das bett ausgiebig
testen runde schlafen und dann schauen
wir uns das hotelzimmer morgen im hellen
noch ein bisschen genauer an
[Musik]
tag nummer zwei ich habe super gut
geschlafen aber das zimmer ist natürlich
nicht das einzige was das hotel zu
bieten hat was es sonst noch so gibt es
jetzt
[Musik]
ich befinde mich auf dem rooftop von
unserem hotel und bin komplett allein
ich bin mitten an der fifth avenue
überall um mich herum wolkenkratzer das
ganze hier ist an sich schon ziemlich
cool aber ich habe mich gerade
erschreckt als wir noch eine sache
aufgefallen ist wenn wir in den vorderen
bereich der bar gehen gibt es ein glas
und man kann komplett nach unten schauen
ich stehe gerade wahrscheinlich
schätzungsweise 120 meter über der
straße
das ist völlig verrückt und außer dem
hier geht es natürlich auch komplett
runter einfach ohne abgrenzung was ich
mich jetzt gar noch frage ist das da
oben ein whirlpool weil es gibt eine
leiter um den verein zu steigen das und
holz ding aber ich glaube eigentlich
nichts kann ich dich sein wenn man jetzt
sehr gewieft wäre könnte man einen laden
gehen sich frühstück kaufen und
kostenlosen dieses rooftop benutzen
richtig richtig geil aber gibt's ja
eigentlich kein frühstück leider nicht
das ganze lag aber nur daran dass ich
quasi in der krone hochphase da war
deswegen beide restaurants im hotel
geschlossen hatten das ganze war aber
nicht mehr schlimm man ist ja nach wie
vor in new york wo es unendlich viel
gutes tribut gibt dort einfach was
gekauft und mit auf die rooftop bar
genommen okay die bewertung welches der
hotels ist denn jetzt schlussendlich
besser für 100 euro das sind new york
oder das in deutschland starten mit dem
treffer aus in köln das zimmer
unglaublich gut gut durchdacht schöne
größe viel größer als das in new york
das zimmer bekommt von mir eine
viereinhalb von fünf sternen ich bin
wirklich begeistert des service was soll
ich sagen empfang war super ansonsten
habe ich den service jetzt nicht
ausgiebig getestet die bedienung im
restaurant war super alles bestens vier
von fünf sternen verpflegung sagen wir
815 8 von 10 oder 4 von 5 sternen für
das hotel in deutschland sauberkeit ich
glaube tatsächlich dass ich noch nie ein
hotel getestet habe das so sauber war
wie das training aus und das war auch
mein eindruck den ich sonst in den
nächten davor bekommen habe wo ich ohne
video geschlafen fünf sternen für die
sauberkeit und es war wirklich top notch
die lage wegen guter lage und keiner
besonders schönen umgebung was er auch
einfach köln geschuldet ist drei halb
von fünf sternen preis und dieses mal
preis-leistung ich bin absolut davon
überzeugt dass es die beste hotelkette
in europa preis leistungsmäßig ist das
ist für mich eine absolute 55 dieses
zimmer hat mit 108 euro pro nacht kostet
also für 108 euro ist das das beste was
man bekommen kann da bin ich absolut
überzeugt schön und gut es ist eines
meiner lieblings hotels aber wie hat
jetzt das alu nomad in new york
abgeschlossen in dem ich vorher noch nie
geschlafen zimmer erstmal vorweg die
glasfront mit diesem ausblick ist
natürlich unschlagbar so was habe ich
vorher noch nie erlebt auf der anderen
seite sie wissen eben dass man nur für
die fenster und für den bruder ist
dadurch ist das zimmer ein bisschen
kleiner und das gibt tatsächlich ein
paar abzüge ich würde dem zimmer eine
viereinhalb von fünf sternen geben es
geht nicht anders weil das zimmer doch
wirklich klein ist um zum beispiel das
waschbecken nicht im bad mit drin ist
sondern irgendwie im flur des zimmers
aber der view ist halt komplett gestört
service ich hatte schon irgendwie das
gefühl dass der service in crystal
darunter leidet dass man direkt inmitten
von new yorks unter unglaublich viel los
und die leute irgendwie ein bisschen
überarbeitet wirken und das einfach nur
ein schnelles apfelstücken war und jetzt
nicht so super herzlich das kann ich
verstehen gibt aber punktabzug
dreieinhalb von fünf sternen verpflegung
weil ich mitten während corinna
hochphase corona in new york war waren
alle ressorts im anno mitbeschlossen
mann hatte trotzdem zugang zur rooftop
bars cool gewesen ist denn man hätte
sich einfach dass street food was man
über den royalen mega gut und einfach
bekommen kann mit auf die dachterrasse
nehmen können um mit quasi davon zu
profitieren
verpflegung vom hotel direkt lässt sich
also nicht einschätzen wir waren aber in
new york das war alles geld und ich
hätte das luftdruck nutzen können also
vier von fünf sternen die sauberkeit im
hotel in new york war leider nicht mit
der vom 25 aus zu vergleichen deswegen
für mich nur drei von fünf sternen lager
unglaublich gut super zentral für
touristen perfekt man ist direkt an der
fifth avenue und kommt von da sie aber
schnell in den central park und so
weiter die leute mit denen ich in
amerika unterwegs war waren eher so ein
bisschen richtung so orientiert es wirkt
einfach als wer da so ein bisschen das
coole or in new york leben was man sich
so erhofft als oben wirklich am time
square ins oder will man eigentlich ab
dem zweiten tag nicht mehr so richtig
sein ansonsten alles bestens vier von
fünf sternen der preis eigentlich kostet
das zimmer so um die 250 dollar ich habe
aber wegen irgend einem online deal über
mileys so ca 120 dollar bezahlt was
unglaubliches dieser ausblick ist
wirklich einmalig und wer das erleben
will sollte meiner meinung nach bereits
120 dollar von 18 bezahlen das bedeutet
ihr auch dass man zu zweit in diesem
zimmer schlafen können nur 60 dollar pro
person pro nacht gezahlt hätte das ist
für mich eine absolute von fünf keine
frage ich weiß gar nicht was sich jetzt
erzählt habe das sind die punkte von dem
hotel aus deutschland das sind die aus
new york das bedeutet das ist der
gewinner der 100 euro tel beide hotels
sind absolut zu empfehlen ich danke dass
ihr dieses video bisschen angeschaut
habt vergesst nicht das video zu leiten
und den kanal zu abonnieren vielen dank
fürs unterstützen wir sehen uns in den
nächsten tagen wieder macht's gut